Right hi everyone, as Lindsay
said my name is Bryan Hughes, I am a front-end
developer at Rdio a music streaming company
in San Francisco. I am also the lead organiser
for Meetup group in San Francisco, a member
of 2 node.js working group, a somewhat regular
speaker at conferences and a popular open
source project. You could say I am pretty
involved these days. Today I am going to talk
about how to get involved yourself.
Most developers tend to go to work and come
home each day, that’s the extent of their
involvement in tech this is perfectly ok too,
I was one of these developers for the first
3 years of my career. There's a lot more out
there though, there are conferences such as
this one, there's meetups, open source projects,
logging and more. As Cate Hutson talked about
on Friday, getting involved in the community
outside of work can be highly rewarding and
sometimes even necessary but also entails
risks especially for people from under-represented
groups. I want to tell my story of how I got
involved in the node.js communities and the
lessons I learned along the way.
My journey started one summer at a resort
in Florida in the US. I was at J conference
2013 at the recommendation of friend and I
was forever changed. It was there that I first
learned about NodeBots and I was hooked immediately.
Of course I was hooked, why not? It's JavaScript
and robots, what's not to love about that?
But more importantly though, this where I
first met Raquel Valez, AKA a truly amazing
person. I wouldn't be here today or be involved
in robotics if it wasn't for her. I was first
inspired to speak at a conference myself.
Soon after the conference one of the speakers
there wrote a blog post titled ‘You Should
Speak at JSConf.’ Still coming off the high
of the conference I thought you know maybe
he's right, maybe I could do this too. So
full of excitement and energy I submitted
a top proposal for JSConf2014 and it was rejected
probably with a fiery burning passion because
my proposal was pretty terrible. That's ok.
We always suck the first time we try to do
something new. No-one rides a bike perfectly
the first time, why should public speaking
be any different. It takes time and practice
but like riding a bike it's a lot of fun it
helps if you have someone teaching you how
to ride though.
After JSConf I followed Raquel on Twitter
I soon found out about NodeBots.sf a JavaScript
meetup in San Fran. I attended my first meetup,
it was incredible. I met many more awesome
people there so by then my course was set.
At a new favourite meetup I found my community.
I didn't let my first talk rejection get to
me too much I realised my first proposal was
terrible I scrapped that entire idea and came
up with a new one. I had been
working with raspberrypi, like I thought that
a lot of people might want to hear about it
too I wrote a new proposal for Cascadia.js
2014, it was also pretty bad. It was an improvement
over my previous one but certainly still wasn't
good and so it was rejected too. Now in this
proposal which was public, I made a mention
of Johnny-five, a JavaScript robotics library.
This attracted the attention of the project's
creator as part of our back and forth online
he mentioned we should get raspberry pi support
into Johnny-five I never worked on an open
source project that wasn't Java related before,
the thought had not even crossed my mind but
now I was intrigued. I wrote a quick plug-in
for Johnny-five and submitted a pull request,
this request was also, it was slow, missing
support for pretty much everything, had no
unit test or any documentation. This is also
ok. Because the first version of new software
are usually really incomplete, they get better
over time. Since I have rewritten the entire
library I have given it a lot of love it's
actually pretty good now. It implements all
the features it needs to be pretty optimised,
has really good documentation to it, but there's
still a lot I want to do with it, a lot, the
least of which is unit tests that are still
missing to this day. Getting involved is an
ongoing process, its ok when you don't get
everything right the first time. There's plenty
of time for that later. You know I am still
very glad I wrote this plug-in, knowing that
other people are using my software to create
amazing art is immensely gratifying. I also
learned that you never know where opportunities
is going to come from, so always be open to
new experiences.
I still wasn't up to public speaking after
my Cascadia.js rejection, I think I set my
sights a bit high. I decided to try something
a bit smaller. In the middle of 2014 some
friends I knew started a new conference called
forward.js, playing round with ECMAScript
6. I decided to submit a proposal for a short
15 minute talk on some odds this proposal
actually wasn't developed, in fact it was
kind of decent, I submitted this proposal
and this time it was accepted. So it was the
first time I had given a talk at a conference
and it went pretty well, it wasn't great,
but pretty well. At the time I was really
worried that someone would ask me questions
about ES6 that I didn't know the answer to,
but at the time there was actually quite bit
about ES6 I didn't know. My fears were completely
unfounded, there was one question I couldn't
answer, and even that wasn't a big deal. I
have since learned that you don't have to
be an expert on a topic to speak about that
topic and conference organisers want you to
talk and they want to help you be awesome.
When you see someone speaking at a conference
or organising an event or leading a popular
open source project it's easy to think they
are naturally gifted, they were somehow born
for it. We tend to put experts on a pedestal
we think they are expert in everything, just
because they are pretty knowledgeable about
this one thing. What you often don't see is
how much we actually don't know, how much
we have failed along the way and all the other
people that helped get us on this stage. Those
of us speaking here at JSConfEU, we have failed
a lot. We weren't born for it, we don't really
know what we're doing, and you know we're
not experts at least not in the sense that
most people assume we are. We're just regular
people who decide to take a risk one day.
Around the same time I submitted my forward.js
proposal I was at an all day NodeBot access
hacka events. Raquel casually mentioned to
me maybe I should organise the meeting. I
had not given organising a second thought
at this point, surely organisers have tons
of experience being organising for forever,
how could I possibly help organise, I am so
new I just screw it up they wouldn't want
me anyway. Round and round my head went. Raquel
made me think otherwise. I reached out to
her and Dan Shaw, the other lead organiser.
As it turned out the timing couldn't have
been better, the current organisers were working
on some awesome new things and they didn't
have as much time to devote to NodeBots.sf
as they once did. This is when I got to know
Dan Shaw better, he's been so helpful I knew
nothing about organising going in. That's
ok. We all start at nothing, but we don't
have to do it alone. There are other people
willing to help you if you are willing to
take the risk and try it. Dan Shaw along with
a few others were ones that help me. We don't
become speakers or organisers or project leaders
because we’re innately more talented than
other people, we're not. We get involved because
other people came before us and they were
supportive enough, and generous enough and
welcoming enough, to give us a chance and
help us succeed.
It's our responsibility to pay it forward
too. One day earlier this year I was hanging
out in the Johnny-five chap room someone dropped
a link to a node.js that recommend we start
node.js hardware working group. My other experience
so far had taught me to jump on opportunities
presented to me even I don't think I am qualified
I thought sure what the hell. Now I am the
de facto lead for the node.js hardware working
group, not sure how that happened exactly
definitely working out how to lead in online
group but things are happening. Then no conference
US happened there were a number of discussions
about diversity and the node.js collaborators
in particular. One of discussion was the node.js
diversity working group I am also a member
of it. This group is still very new we're
still figuring our what our mission is exactly.
There have been some very tough challenges
for this group to solve as well, I am excited
but still nervous to see where it goes. I
hope I am able to bring some value to this
working group although I constantly question
my abilities of being able to do so. One point
I actually thought about quitting the group
altogether because the challenges seemed insurmountable.
Then someone I have never met before, commented
on a PR I had open someone whose affected
by the lack of diversity in the node.js collaborators.
Their comments and kind words gave me the
determination that I lacked until then. I
might have quit without them.
People don't just help us get into a community,
they are the reason that we stay. When I think
of everything that important in my life in
the end it's all about people. That's what
motivates me the people, and I think that's
what motivates most everyone else too.
Looking back across the years I realise I
suffer from imposter syndrome, I am simply
going to read this definition to you. “Imposter
syndrome is a situation where someone feels
like an imposter or fraud, they feel their
accomplishments are nowhere near as good as
those of the people
round them. Usually their accomplishments
are just as good and the person is applying
a unfairly high standard to themselves and
not to others.”
You know, I think this is something we're
all prone to, it's human nature, but it's
important that we recognise it for what it
is though, a trick that our minds play on
us, I sincerely believe that every single
one of you in the audience is capable of speaking
at an conference of contributing to an open
source project of writing blog posts we're
not going to be great at all of these things,
very few people are but everyone has talent
at something.
I realise that the title of this talk is the
risks and rewards of getting involved in how
to do, I have not talked about the risk or
how to do it have I, let me address the how
to do it first.
If I have not made it obvious already, it's
not as hard as people through it's not some
drama we put you through, nor do we only accept
the best of the best of the best. If you are
willing to put yourself out there we'll help
you on your journey. If you feel motivated
to do something, commit to that motivation,
then reach out to others already doing it.
Yep that's it, that's the secret to getting
involved. Commit to doing, it then ask for
help.
When you feel motivated or the thing is though
the process is easier for some people than
it is for others. Exclusion, marginalisation
and existing lack of diversity are very real
problems conspire to keep under represented
people out of our development communities.
I am going to switch gears and we're going
to talk about this. I am going to start as
I have everything else with a story.
So, I grew up in a conservative part of Texas
in the United States I'm also a liberal, bisexual,
atheist, among other things, I did not belong
in Texas, San Francisco seemed like a paradise,
it was far from the reason I moved there,
I thought San Francisco was better, companies
were diverse and welcoming,, it wasn't the
cesspool of disablist, racist, xenophobic
assholes that it is!
As a - I encountered bigotry, I was more or
less used to it, I was also an out back fan,
there is that too. I didn't view myself as
part of the problem, I mean, I never hit on
women or men at professional events, I never
said anything overtly misogynistic online
or indulge in harassing behaviour, surely
I was one of the good guys right, well no,
I wasn't. I was contributing to the problem
in my own way, I see that now.
Back then I had no idea what microaggressions
were, what intersectionality was, that being
silent maintained the status quo and the status
quo was pretty terrible. Here is the truth
of the matter, the tech industry card deck
is stacked, you white, white, American white
male straight, you are automatically at a
disadvantage, our industry is fundamentally
broken and we are all implicit not standing
against the current status quo is to support
it, it's to condone harassment and abuse,
sitting comfortably in your own situation,
ignoring those around you suffering, is to
say, "Fuck you, I've got mine", if you
aren't contributing to make are industry better
you are contributing to making it worse. Me,
I was part of the problem, I was contributing
to making it worse. I still am to some extent,
but, now I'm trying to be part of the solution
too.
So, what changed? I started listening. I started
believing women, people of colour, LGBT, disabled,
when they say there is a problem. To be clear
I'm not an expert on this stuff, not even
close, I don't think I ever can be. I still
screw up. That's ok too, as long as I catch
myself or have someone call me out on it apologise
promptly and take steps not to do it again,
these last steps are critical, making mistakes
are own, we're only human and we're going
to make mistakes, but not learning from those
mistakes and repeating them over hand over
hand over again, that is real harm. So, a
few years ago, I was really unhappy at a previous
job. At the time it was difficult for me to
put my finger on exactly why it was unhappy,
later on I came to realise it was because
this company was pretty typical for Silicon
Valley, misogynistic and homophobic and on
and on and on, the culture of this company
was the antithesis of inclusivity, shouting
attacks, poor reports from meetings, home
phobic slurs used frequently by everybody
up and down the power chain, social justice
voyeurs and the PC police, stories and rumours
of much, much worse. There is a reason that
there are only two women engineers in a team
of 60 and both of them were brought in through
acquisitions, the company didn't care about
hiring women and if they did there was a hostile
work environment for any woman unlucky enough
to enter. For me, I didn't feel comfortable
being myself there, I didn't come out to a
single co-worker, I was scared to come out,
I didn't feel I would be accepted for who
I was and would face a wave of harassment
if I did, so I quit, it was the single best
thing I did for my entire career. I'm picking
on this company, not because they are noteworthy,
but because they are average, that's a problem.
When I went looking for a new job my number
one requirement was a not terrible culture,
everything else was secondary. I found Rdio,
it's made up of some pretty amazing people,
we're not perfect and we still have some work
to do to make the culture better and increase
diversity, I'm actually optimistic we can
do it, I'm comfortable being myself there.
So, what does this all have to do with community?
Well, my experiences of life and work taught
me something crucially important, what I learned
is this: the reason many people get involved,
or stay involved, or leave the community or
quit a job is directly related to how comfortable
they're being themselves, this is true whether
it's an employer, a communicate, a circle
of friends or a family. You know, we have
to be kind to one another, we have to be,
all of us. Even if you are not an organiser
a regular speaker or attendee even, we are
all responsible, organisers are the ones that
set the initial culture for the community
and they have to take disciplinary action
when needed, but you know we can't be everywhere
at once, we are not privy between very conversation
or interaction, we have to change it to where
entitled people are sensitive to not saying
bigoted things, but where people say thing
irregardless of sexual orientation, race gender
or anything else.
I was at a robotics conference last year,
amazing speakers, code of conduct and organisers
that genuinely care about the community, one
of my best friends, was there as an invited
expert, hanging out at a booth with
her hardware, this guy asks her point-blank,
"Did you bad build this?" In a single sentence
he managed to dismiss her abilities and make
her feel excluded, I was there as an invited
expert to, no one said that to me or any of
the other invited experts that were men, whether
it was in intentional or not, it happened
because she was a woman. These kinds of incidents
happen all the time too, there have been probably
been at least 100 similar incidents happening
here too, organisers can't be everywhere at
once, we need your help.
So, how can you help? Well, the first step
is knowing what to look for. We tend to know
our own worlds well, what people similar to
us are going through, the key is being able
to cull activate a basic understanding of
people not like us are going through, it takes
a considered effort to learn and requires
a lot of practice, it's really hard, it's
also really necessary. So, start learning
about social justice, you know, understand
what privilege is and how it manifests itself.
Listen to and believe when, people of colour,
LGBT, the disabled and others when they speak
about harassment and exclusion. When someone
calls you out on your inappropriate behaviour,
apologise properly, think about what you did
and change your behaviour. Call out others
when they are acting inappropriately and do
it in the moment, if it's safe to do so. It
may be scary and awkward, it may make others
uncomfortable, but that's actually the point.
Making people uncomfortable and upset is how
we affect change. If you are more involved
already, recognise you have a responsibility
to the rest of the community, don't speak
or attend conferences that don't have a code
of conduct or are known for a hostile environment,
make it known publicly why you are not attending.
For people in positions of power, make sure
you are building a good community, make inclusivity
a central pillar of every last thing that
you do.
You know, don't just let it be an after thought.
How you treat people, in the community that
you build, are the only things that matter
in the end. Don't know where to start, the
Geek Feminism Wiki, model view culture who's
links are in here in the slide are excellent
resources and I encourage you all to view
them.
The Johnny-Five community is good so far as
communities go, we're not perfect, no one
is there are lot of caring and empathetic
people in the community, others communities
can be like this too, not just communities,
our work places can be better as well. Bosses
aren't the only ones responsible for creating
safe spaces even if they share the bulk of
the burden, we all play a part in making our
own work places better.
When it comes to people, the tech industry
is broken, it's the new Wall Street, we suffer
from a severe lack of diversity and diversity
is actually getting worse, not better. Lack
of diversity hurts business. It hurts productivity,
it hurts creativity. An industry of young,
affluent, kiss gender white male, only caters
to the young able white kiss gender white
men, it assists the majority of the population
of this planet, for fundamental and far more
important, lack of diversity hurts people.
It hurts are brothers and sisters, fuck the
business case, this is about people and dignity
and respect
and making the world a better place, not just
for a few, but for everyone. Our industry
doesn't have to be terrible. We can actually
be the sources of hope and change we so often
like to pretend that we are. We can be a part
of communities filled with empathy and love
and respect for everyone. We can make this
happen, but all of us, all of us, are needed
to make that difference.
Thank you. .